all right so
welcome back everybody so the last talk
of the morning session is by may sam
raza via in
from uh
usa thank you
but thank you very much costas um it's a
pleasure to be here
so today i'm going to talk about solving
certain classes of non-convex minimax
optimization problem
this is a joint work based on
my works with many colleagues but the
parts that i'll focus on mostly it's a
joint work with my student bought back
andrew and dimitri
was that in the job market this year
so um we have heard uh
many interesting talks about me max
optimization problem this talk is also
about min max optimization problem
i'm going to make some assumptions
throughout the talk
basically i'm going to assume that you
have a min max problem that your
constraint sets
are closed and convex
these are going to be uh zoom throughout
talk
i'm going to assume uh that your
function is smooth uh l is smooth which
is continuous gradient uh it could be
possibly non-convex basically our focus
is non-convex although some of the
results that i'll talk about they are
generalized and we have generalized it
to stochastic settings and some
non-smooth settings that they proximal
friendly there you can easily extend the
results
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start with some motivation very quickly
because you have heard a lot and some
applications
the application will help us to
also talk about and motivate what do i
need from an algorithm
and talk about some solvable cases
and by solving i put it down always in
quotation marks because i'm going to
talk about what do i mean by someone
and essentially what we are going to see
is that
this problem and the notion of solving c
that we'll talk about
is
solvable
and there are we talk about some
algorithms and convergence rates rates
when for example your f
objective function is concave or
strongly con
k in alpha it could be non-convex and
theta
you see that it is solvable when there
is a small coupling between the two
values
meaning that your the
haitian of uh f then you take the first
derivative respect to theta second
derivative with respect to alpha this
coupling is small and also the third
case then your the radius of this that a
is a small
see that these are the cases that we can
develop some efficient algorithms
uh for solving
and please throw out the talk and stop
me and ask questions if you have any
questions
so let me quickly give you a simple
motivating example
motivation for
us in the stock is one motivation is
designing robust systems
you know that when we want to design a
system for example minimize the cost
analyzing the energy costs something
else error in your for example
classifier you typically minimize your
objective with respect to some nominal
value of parameters let's say alpha not
but when you want to have a robust
design
you may have allow some perturbations
of alpha and you minimize for the worst
case
and that leads to a min max optimization
this appears in many different domains
ranging from for example
robust design of beamforming design and
wireless communications to
adversarial
defense against adversarial attacks that
we have seen a lot of examples of it
during this workshop
it appears in other applications uh such
as guns uh
training fair machine learning models
disturb distribution low robust learning
all of it uh that other speakers talked
about so i'm gonna escape
so you have seen on slides like this a
lot of you have seen it a lot here in
the past stocks as well so are
non-convex min max problems challenging
to solve
and to understand it i'm going to
compare and contrast put it side by side
by regular minimization soon for example
i want to
train a regular network
i want to try and robust that basically
in the left hand side problem
okay left hand side of the problem you
want to find the best parameter w so
that given your input data x
yeah you have the minimum uh training
loss
and this l is you can think of it as a
erm loss summation of all
classes the right hand side is you can
step for worst-case perturbation at
delta
that is basically you would solve a min
max term
and
um
so we saw some hardness results this
morning uh manolis had a very nice talk
about the hardness result but i'm going
to talk about basically impactors are
the problems that we see in practice are
they really hard
or like the difficult case doesn't
appear
so when you have a regular minimization
and you give it to a practitioner they
typically for example we can run
gradient descent it has some nice
properties
the nice properties are that objective
function improves ovaries threats
meaning that if you start running the
algorithm and you stop it after one hour
you most always we are like we know that
we are at a better point
uh for example when i run projected
gradient or gradient design
the algorithm is dimension independent
converged iteration complexity meaning
that we can run gradient descent on
each scale when the number of parameters
are large and still have a
like expect
fast convergence
it is very well studied we know the
alteration complexity upper and lower
but on the right hand side one of the
popular ones approaches that's used a
lot in practice is gradient senescent
for example
that today we have
seen also a lot of examples of it
but is this algorithm convergent i know
that we have talked we have seen
examples such as
x times y like w times delta example
that this diverges you have limit cycles
but i'm i'm applying this gradient to 10
as an algorithm to training a robust
network okay and also a regular training
and
basically what i did what we did here is
a simple small neural network with uh
on mnist data we compared the regular
minimization with the mean max
formulation this type of transition now
we run random epochs for different step
sizes we randomly choose as exercise
within the range that we knew that like
there are almost convergent results
and you can see that most of the times
so okay so the x-axis here
is the accuracy that you get
and this is the histogram
out of like 50 runs that we had
and we chose different step sizes for
each run
okay and you see that for regular
minimization most of the times you get
the accuracy which is close to 100
percent okay but you have also failures
but when you do this formulation or you
follow this dynamics most of the times
you end up at even after 10 epochs for a
long time you end up at the point
basically it's 10 percent accuracy and
you have 10 classes it means that you
are random you are basically
it's not an interesting poll
that's not just the step size if you
repeat it for example for different
batch sizes you see the same thing
regular minimization um
it almost always converges in our
experiment mean max many times doesn't
compare it's also like if you
find the best batch size best step size
that works for everyone but just
randomly change the seed value
the regular minimization always
converges but the mean max formulation
doesn't converge in any case
so
it's basically not a very reliable
uh algorithm and we have seen like what
the issues are
so this means that it's not that uh they
are hard in extreme cases as my analyst
was talking about it but also at the
hardness we see it in practice
uh so sorry two questions so
the fact that first of all the accuracy
isn't great doesn't mean it didn't
converge i mean
we have to separate the two that's a
very good point okay
that's a very good we checked okay
uh we tried to see well whether it's
convergent or not and it's not but we
could not like plot that and show it
very well like it's
jumping around so you could like if we
could like uh plot it in a 2d animation
we could still see it but we have a lot
of like variables
that's a very good point
uh
so and then uh
we know that certain stationary notions
are difficult to compute uh as we saw
talking this morning
but mean max problems they appear in
practice so
um now i ask a question of any solvable
problem instances or any solve over
problem classes that we can focus on
um for me max
and when i talk about solvable we have
to
decide what do we mean by solvable and
what is the solution concept that you
are looking at there
generally at the higher level we can
think of min max formulations
as a bi-level viewpoint or stack of work
that your goal is to minimize this g of
theta okay which is the max is defined
as max over alpha of state and alpha
so your final ultimate goal is to
work with g so g is matters for you
another way is to look at it as a game
nash game
type 2 player
all fanfic
and you can define your notion of
optimal of your stationarity based on
the viewpoint that you have
for example on the nashville point
you are happy
if for example in the unconstrained case
your gradient neural norm with respect
to phaeton of a small
the constraint you can look at the
proximal gradient node for example
in the bio-level stack or a stackelberg
viewpoint
which i focus on just during this talk
our focus is we say that theta star is a
reasonable station point if the gradient
of g
is small g is this function
again g may not be differentiable in
general so we are going to use a
borrower envelope of g smooth some
smooth version of that
let's use more envelope in this stock
so and the two solution concepts are in
general different they are they don't
coincide it's you cannot you can come up
with simple examples such as this
example uh you can also add
like bounds if you want theta between
minus -1 and 1.
in this example
if you plot the g function which is this
maximum this is your g function
it's nice convex function
and the only reasonable solution seems
to be a theta star equals to minus one
if you look at it from bi-level
viewpoint but if you look at it from
game perspective does uh nash
equilibrium or first order nash
equilibrium or the solution to vi
is zero and zero so they don't
necessarily uh the solution concepts uh
coincide
but in some cases such as non-convex
concave uh when you have non when your f
is concave in alpha you have a compact
set a
then the two solution concepts coincide
and during this talk as i mentioned i'm
looking at
this by level viewpoint and the reason
is that
one of the motivating examples the
motivation is
robustness
and when we look at the robustness we
want to find the parameter theta that
works uniformly well or well across all
choices of alpha so what matters for us
is mostly this g
um
so
now that we know what the solution
concept we are looking for let me tell
let me talk about what algorithms you
are looking for
so the algorithms again i listed the
properties that we have nice properties
when we focus on regular minimization
for example when we looked at gradient
descent we saw that the objective
function improves or rethreads it means
that when you start
you stop after like an hour you are
almost certain that you get a better
point
uh
if the algorithm
stops when you are using projected
gradient descent for minimizing a
function the algorithm stops or jump
arounds or you go to like you look at
the limit points
they are uh stationary
and for nice problems or convex problems
these are optimal points uh
and the convergence rates are dimension
independent
now
i want to focus on algorithms that they
have also these properties
okay for me in that spot
and
this is a summary of basically the
results that i'm going to talk about
so three cases we are going to talk
about and the rates that we get
basically the three cases that we can
have an algorithm that satisfy those
properties
is when your f is concave in alpha when
you have a small adversary domain is
that the diameter of this constant that
a is small
it's comparable to your desired accuracy
and then you have a small coupling
meaning that the
parameter that corresponds to this
uh hessian with respect to theta and
alpha take the first derivative of theta
and measure
uh like the second order of the circle
alpha these
a good things
those three are independent i mean no
these three are like no yeah these are
or
not and okay so if this happens or this
or this you can come up with an
algorithm that's a very good
um
and we again find a station point for g
uh
and the algorithms are going to almost
always improve the objective at each
iteration
improve your g
so let me start by the simple case of
non-convex strongly concave setting
so
again my aim is to minimize g so let's
try to minimize g
i can try to apply gradient descending g
but we don't have access to the gradient
of g directly so this is projected
gradient descent this plus means that i
do projection
so i do i don't have access to the
gradient of g and it's uh
and it's well it is differentiable when
the function is strongly concave
but i have
indirectly have access to the gradient
of g through dansko's theorem that's
this theorem says that the gradient of g
at the given point eight not
is the same as gradient of f i take the
knot
when you replace alpha with the optimal
off
so if you find the optimal alpine take
the gradient of f then that gives you
great image and this simple observation
gives you a basically an algorithm
so you can have an algorithm like this
you approximately solve with respect to
alpha solve this maximization and then
you do one gradient sense that
perspective data
and
you can show it like uh the convergence
result uh this is
what we show like very early
jason and uh
mazda asia here also in the audience
that if you have if you run this
algorithm
uh you need all order epsilon minus two
of two logarithmic factors of gradient
evaluations for computing state that's
not stationary solutions
and the reason for this rate is that you
are mimicking the behavior of gradient
descent on the function g which is this
max so this is the number of gradient
descents that you need this needs from
the classical result of non-convex
smooth minimization in the order so
minus two iterations on theta
and this is strongly concave so you can
you need
logarithmic
you have logarithmic dependence on apps
uh
and it's up to logarithmic factor
optimal you can generalize this also to
pl cases
uh
so you need to establish nonsense type
result for pl under pl assumptions but
you can do that so that tells you that
if your f is also
not strongly concave in alpha but
strongly concave composite with affine
you still can get a restraint
now the next step is that can i relax it
a little bit so let's relax this strong
concavity assumption
and go to concave assumption concave
case
so what happens when you have
non-context concave scenario
so now our f is concave in alpha but not
strongly
again i can try to apply gradient
descent or some descend method on g
but g is no longer differentiable in
this case necessarily
a maximum of a concave function it's not
not necessarily
uh it's differentiable so a simple trick
is to smooth the piece okay so i can
smoothify g
basically
use the idea that the algorithm that we
had before i make it strongly concave
first
with respect to alpha
and then apply our figures out i just
need to make sure that my lambda is
small enough so that it gets me the
desired accuracy
and again the algorithm would be your
you do gradient descent on theta so we
try to mimic the behavior of this
gradient descent dynamics on g
and using done skins again this is a
high level description of the algorithm
you apply
some algorithm software's order
algorithm
gradient ascent for example to solve
this problem and then do you do one step
of gradient understand respect to theta
and you can analyze it if you for
example
do next draw to get a faster rate
this tells you that
uh you need
this you can analyze now you see that
you need order allah
personal minus 3.5
uh
gradient evaluations for computing
uh stationarity in terms of the
nash equilibrium viewpoint uh
and epsilon minus four in terms of uh
stack up our viewpoint
as i said when you have concavity the
two notions are related so you can
compute that
great the number of gradient evaluations
for both
um so any questions so far
okay so the question that i want to
focus is that why does it become so much
slower compared to the previous case we
had a strong
concave case which was epsilon minus two
and now we went to epsilon minus four x
minus three point five
why we lose so much how like rate
or why do we observe significant rates
the reason that we observe a significant
rate drop is that if you want to find
that epsilon stationary point as i
mentioned this problem should be a good
approximation of this problem
to guarantee that the point that you get
the solution that you get by solving
this problem is indeed the solution of
the original problem you have to choose
your lambda small it turns out if you
analyze it your lambda should be ordered
the epsilon in fact we accurate it
should be epsilon divided by the radius
of
the constraint on alpha
and
so when you choose lambda we order
epsilon
and you minimize this g of lambda which
is this max
what we know is that the step size that
we choose should be inversely
proportional to the ellipses constant so
we know like we also learned from the
last uh
during all of the talks see that step
size that you have is one over l the
order
so it turns out that uh the licious
constants of this g lambda you can
analyze it's not very difficult
is
need inversely proportional to lambda so
your eta depends it's inversely for it's
one over liquids constant of g
and the diffusion constant of g is one
over
lump
uh
so in other words your eta should be
ordered as epsilon so your step size
should be very small
if you run this out
now we know it's like uh
you know that
you cannot use arbitrary step size
you cannot because if you choose it very
large you may go and increase your
objective
well if you can look at the future so if
you can look here when i'm moving here i
look here and i see okay my step my
gradient is going down very quickly it
seems that my haitian is large
so i can take larger step size
and that is uh the idea of proximal
point algorithm that has been seen also
multiple times during this workshop in
particular
if you can follow this dynamics you can
choose arbitrary step size okay so if i
choose any like any eta this algorithm
guarantee gives you decrease and the
reason is that this
dynamic here is equivalent to this one
the proximal point
which you can see that when you do take
g of theta t plus one is less than or
equal g of theta t
and no matter what a triggers
so if we want to choose a
large step size to have a faster
convergence rate
you have to follow proximal point since
one idea is to follow proximal point
so if i want to apply proximal point on
this minimum for minimizing g of lambda
each step
i need to solve
this optimization or this sub problem
but this is uh
this might not be easy so let's first
replace the definition of g of lambda
here
g of lambda is the max of this function
so i need to solve this problem
again if i try to solve it in this order
i want to basically
mimic replicate this dynamic using a
gradient dynamics okay
because uh we want to work with the
first order method so we want to follow
use the gradients of
f now the question is how can i use the
gradient of f to follow this uh dynamics
to replicate or mimic the behavior after
step
so again if i do it in this order
then
again i have a strongly concave function
inside with respect to alpha with a
small lambda
and that gives me a
large
ellipses constant for the function which
is the max of this
okay
so and that gives me basically a again a
rate trough so what you can do but right
now is that since this problem right now
is con strongly conducts strongly
concave because after you add a
regularizer this becomes astronomic
conduction theta and strongly concave in
alpha you can switch min and max
okay and you can solve it in this one
so what happens here is that right now
if you for example you choose your eta
to be one over ellipses constant
you have an optimization problem with
the constant condition number in theta
because it's uh
you can make the
uh strong convex modulus of theta to be
order l you can make it l half
and then so the inner minimization
now can be solved order constant okay
because it's strongly convex or up to
logarithms this uh the
solving the minimization astronomy
conducts order square upper
log one over epsilon right so kappa
right now is order one so you can solve
this minimization inside minimization or
the constant
and for the outside uh when you solve it
you can get to any desired accuracy that
you want you can get the gradient of the
outside problem
and for that you can use for example now
an ester of acceleration for the outside
and you can repeat this basically you
can repeat this algorithm and that gives
you
this rate of convergence it's actually
very easy to establish this
just by using the building block
existing building blocks up
nestor of acceleration combining
basically to solve this inner
minimization with the gradient descent
gradient descent respect to theta
then you do accelerate master of outside
and that you have the desired accuracy
you update your theta goes to the next
this the switch of minion max
is only holds for a teller is very small
correct uh yeah uh so it's because the
function f is not convex in theta so i
choose my eta to be
1 over 2l
the ellipsis constant of f
okay and if i do that this becomes 1
over 2 eta becomes l
so if you add l
now your ellipses constant of the your
entire function with respect to theta is
2l
your strong convex modulus is
l
we have 2lo rl your condition number is
1.
but yeah that's correct so
uh
so you get did i answer your question
okay so do you get this rate of
convergence and similar rate of
self-convergence actually has been
observed also like in other works um
particle for example kanga and montero
has a
similar get they get a small rate of
convergence but they assume for example
one difference is that they assume they
have access to the
gradient of the smoothness version of
the function
which is different than having access to
the gradient of the original function
because it's not clear in different
applications how do you get access to
the gradient
this paper which appears like
a few weeks after us
it resolved this issue here
but particularly these two
references and both are they also have
similar results which i want to spend
one slide talking about the differences
on terms of the result because this was
actually
one
related to
uh one technical aspect that helped us
use all the building blocks in the
literature
so these two books also get the same
rate of convergence uh although it's for
constraint uh an euclidean proximal the
result that we have it was for
uh
sorry these are for anka so you can work
for constraint
but the most important thing for us was
that when we tried to work with the
standard or the weeks the station notion
that's been used on the other wars
we had uh
we had like technical difficulty
connecting
the accuracy that you need to solve the
inner problem to the outside problem
so
and then the main difference actually
one of the main difference is that
uh that
in terms of it's in the definition of
station
to explain what is the station notion
difference between this fork and the
existing works which helped us also to
establish
uh convergence very easily without like
reducing the building blocks without
developing our own acceleration method
uh so we use for example existing
natural acceleration instead of
developing our own
is that uh
to explain this stationary notion let me
consider and explain it for simple
minimization problem when you minimize
the function h constraint
i'm going to define two estation notions
the first one is the gap in the proximal
which is has been used a lot this is the
second one they both may seem
ugly right now but they have they have
both been used in the literature before
um
but i'm going to tell you that these two
stationers i'm going to explain what
they mean okay in a second but before
that i want to state the theorem that
this station ocean is a stronger notion
in the sense that
this station notion implies the first
one
but the first one does not imply the
second one like for any epsilon prime is
that you may get this one for epsom
but you do not have this for any epsilon
okay
and why do we have this so let's
understand this station notion
definitions
these are you can define it for general
proximal but let's understand it for
projection base
so a point z star is optimal or like
stationary for this problem
when you go to the negative direction of
gradient
and project it back
if you come back to z-star
then we say that this z-star is a
stationary
has been used a lot also it's
you can't think of it as a solution of
vi okay this is the explanation of the
solution to vi that you have
now if you have another point z bar
that's not optimal meaning that when you
go to the negative direction of gradient
and you project back you come to
you come to a different point
i'm going to form this triangle
and i'm going to the length i'm going to
use alpha beta gamma to denote the
length of different size of this
triangle
so the first station in notion
says that after you project this point
minus this point this should be less
than or equal to epsilon i
ignore the normalization with the
ellipsis constant so
basically assume the ellipse is constant
is one for simplicity this stationary
notion says that we are epsilon
stationary if you're gamma
the length of gamma is less than or
equal to
the second one tells you that
you can simplify it and work out like
the geometry the second one tells you
that if alpha square minus beta square
is less than or equal to epsilon squared
this is the second station
and the proof of this theorem is very
simple actually the you can use the law
of cosine because we know that this
angle between beta and gamma
is up to use is more than 90 degree so
we know alpha square minus beta square
is larger than or equal to gamma squared
okay so that tells us two implies one
and it's not very difficult it's
actually it's very hard to see examples
that these are along the same line
and
this gap could be very large
questions
any questions
okay
so what i'm going to do so this is
this was uh basically our result but uh
for non-context concave setting
well we asked the question of now the
next question that i want to ask is that
how much can we go beyond the convex
concave setback
and again i'm looking at the bi-level
viewpoint
and
i'm using two motivating examples two
simple examples
if i have decoupled cases
a problem like this
okay
although it's mean max it might be
non-convex non-concave but if i you are
interested in solution in terms of beta
it's easy to solve it right because you
just apply gradient descent on f1
because f2 is like irrelevant it
decomposes
or if you have a problem in max problem
like this
that your constraint is a single tone
you have a single tone this again mean
max problem is artificial immune axis
essentially minimizes both of them right
because this max is not rel
so these are two very corner cases that
mean max problem is easy
now if you relax it a little bit
essentially the result is that if you're
coupling the small between theta and
alpha or the diameter of a is small then
you can solve the problem of the
stationary notch
but the idea is that we may not be able
to evaluate g exactly to take this
gradient but we can be able to compute
and evaluate the approximation of the
gradient
sorry the gradient of approximation of g
to give you
basically the technical result
if this is the original
problem
we essentially use a taylor expansion
let's look at the taylor expansion of
the problem
okay
so instead of g i will use the taylor
expansion of it
where
i take the max over f tilde k
f tilde k is the k or the taylor
expansion of f
the taylor expansion has respect to
alpha only so it's not respect to theta
and we know that this could be a good
approximation this is a good
approximation if for example the radius
of a is small the diameter of a is small
particular expansion could be a result
approximation
so now there are two questions if i
solve this problem
is this related to the solution that you
get is it related to the original
problem the solution it's the first
question the second question is that can
we solve this problem
okay so i'm going to answer the first
question first uh
just that's solving the approximate
problem solve the original problem to
the desired accuracy
and this is that simplified theorem that
assume that the diameter of the
constants that is a if this condition is
satisfied in other words if your
diameter is like order of your desired
accuracy
or like your
coupling is small
then any epsilon stationary of this
point is an epsilon station of the
origin
oh very good
yeah sorry so
first of all k
is or extension approximation
l theta theta is the lipids constant
of the gradient so
so when you take the derivative of f
with respect to theta
i measure the ellipse constant with
respect to theta
in other words you can think of it if
your function is in c infinity or in c2
you take second order derivative with
respect to theta first and second
respective data and this is the bound
that you have for us
l theta alpha is the bound that you take
the first order derivative with respect
to theta a secondary derivative with
respect to alpha
and there is l alpha k
plus one which is the ellipses constant
on
or the bound and you can take k plus one
order of derivative with respect to
alpha
and d alpha is the diameter of this set
constant
so this essentially says that for
example if i look at this thing if this
is less than or equal to epsilon what
does that mean it means that if your d
alpha is small if your radius is small
or l theta alpha is small means that
your coupling is small relative to your
desired axis this these are the two
corner cases that
and you can get this epsilon stationary
solution by solving the approximate
problem instead of the original
all product questions today
questions all right okay
yes alpha k plus one oh l alpha k plus
one is the
literal constant uh with respect to
alpha the kth or
okay so you take k plus one derivative
with respect to alpha
and that's the upper bound in the form
so this is true for any k okay from 0 1
to whatever k you want so for example is
alpha is 1
this would be the ellipses constant k it
would be alpha 2 or you can think of it
alpha alpha
which is you take two derivative respect
to alpha and that's the upper
so i want to understand that means that
if my function is enough smooth
and i am in a bounded space for example
and the diameter is polynomial
that means that they can show this type
of
equilibrium efficiently no this is up to
epsilon order but epsilon is above us
okay so you can go to this at this
epsilon
you cannot choose epsilon r squared i
cannot go lower than this you cannot go
forward and they split this up
and this tells you that when for example
but this epsilon this value could be a
small if your d alpha is small or like
oh tata alpha small so this is one way
of looking at it that in some coordinate
cases you can solve it
or you can think of it as you can solve
the problem up to this accuracy
not beyond
with this approach that is super large i
should be able to get smaller is that
can you say they can see super large
uh-huh i use very high order trailer i
should have
absolutely
so there are
okay so you may be able to get smaller
like epsom but
larger k but solving the approximate
problem that's not easy
and you go for a larger
sorry
okay yes one last question
that is the constructive or mathematic
with the meaning that
so this result is saying that if you
find an epsilon stationary of this
problem
independent
it's an absolute stationary
yeah
uh
and uh
at least with this approach is uh the
results are order type meaning that
um
the epsilon station if
so
you can think of this as additive
theorem that basically the epsilon
accuracy that you solve this problem and
the epsilon accuracy that you have this
this is the gap that you have between
the two you can think of this as this
this is you can say a show that's order
type being that there are problem
instances uh that you can construct the
problem instead they cannot go beyond
this with this this stretch
that's it
um so the next question is that can we
solve this approximate problem
and this is that um
it's actually it's easy so let's
specialize it for example for k equals
one
so k equals one if my ellipse is
constant for supposedly assume that they
are one
so my d alpha should be order epsilon
okay
and that tells us when your radius of a
is order your desired accuracy
then instead of solving the original
problem you can solve this from
okay
and this problem is non-convex concave
meaning that it's non-convex plane theta
was concave in alpha
okay
so you can use the algorithms like that
we talked about you can get overall
iteration complexity of all epsom minus
2
but you need to have access to the
gradient of this function which should
be the haitian of the original function
because you need to take the derivative
of this there this gives you the h you
can uh relax that by using the finite
differences
if you specialize it to k equals two
and that tells you that our bond tells
you that if your radius is order epsilon
power two third
okay instead of solving the original
problem you can solve this problem
and you can relate to epsilon stationary
and
this problem uh for example when the set
a is euclidean ball this becomes a
thrust region sub problem
and this is a truss region sub problem
and you can solve it you can solve the
inner maximization problem using first
order methods for trusses and there are
many of them you can for example use
this or carmen duchy
and if you show that overall algorithm
that you can get you can using this
method you can have an algorithm with
this order iteration complex
for this class
questions
okay so these are two special cases
uh
my time is over so
uh let me conclude and
some talk about some open question
so
we talked about three special cases that
mean max problem
in the bi-level viewpoint stack of our
viewpoint they're solvable but there are
many open problems still the lower bound
and non-convex concave system
it's open uh
the requirements that for example i had
for cake was 1 and k plus 2 which is
your d
your radius being this order or this
order this is tight using our approach
in that using the taylor expansion
approach you cannot go beyond this
but can i relax this diameter spur is
there any other algorithm that
for example can
improve the radius requirement at some
minus one half
uh epsom one one half instead of epsilon
two theta
uh
the iteration complexity bounds that i
talked about uh for quadratic case is
not also
uh we don't know whether they are
optimal or not uh this is also a fun
question these are some of the
references uh with many of the
colleagues that on the mid max problem i
want to thank all the colleagues and uh
some staff
supporting my research and if you have
any questions up
questions
so when you're uh you're rather than for
non-convex concave um you have this like
strongly convexed on a concrete problem
uh so it's non-convex strong concave but
you know but when you i can't specialize
into strong functions strongly
oh you mean that a lot problem the same
problem oh okay okay uh so this one yes
exactly so i guess there's i don't
remember exactly the results but i think
there's been some work on
solving these problems when like the
condition numbers the
maximization minimization parameters are
unbalanced
um
is is is your like
algorithm that solves this problem like
um get the optimal dependence on the
condition that's a very good point yeah
you can actually
uh i think there is a result
and like the there is also that they
talk about optimal rates this album is
actually simple switch also gets better
okay you can show that's that's that's
right
that's so you can uh like this simple
like uh using proximal and uh
following this proximal and making
all right
thank you again
and we're back at 2pm